a Penn State sociology Professor has
encouraged his students to watch gay
porn
he's not just encouraged his gay
students gay identifying LGBT
identifying students to watch LGBT porn
he's encouraging all of his students to
do that
what's the argument
this is from sociology 119 Professor Sam
Richards says that that
even straight people and especially
straight people should watch gay porn
because they might be aroused by it he
says if you're straight watch gay or
lesbian porn see how quickly you feel
aroused and how you can't control that
you'll realize oh expletive I could be
sexualized by people who are like me
went on to say we are all at some level
non-binary
we're all very much easily bisexual
uh it's not clear what he's pointing to
in terms of the research that would lead
him to this conclusion there was a study
uh conducted by Cornell in 2015 showed
or reclaimed at least that both men and
women were aroused when they watched
porn of the same sex and they said that
this is evidence that everybody's gay or
something everybody's bisexual you know
that thing that totally exists
bisexuality yeah they said that that
everybody was that and the professor
said I might have hit a nerve there did
I hit a nerve
watch gay porn he said see if you feel
that feeling if you feel that feeling
look in the mirror say huh maybe I'm
just feeling some things that I'm just
afraid to release and maybe you release
that and maybe you'd be surprised that
maybe you actually are fine being more
bisexual
and he said he says I have friends who
have spent a long time in prison I'm
sure he has I think that's the only
thing he said so far that's true I have
friends that's been a long time in
prison and they have homosexual sex
they're straight until they're in prison
and then they do that so especially on
the prison point I think what he's
observing is
true enough you're saying yeah you throw
a bunch of guys in prison there's not a
woman in sight and they're all a little
bit deviant to begin with they're
criminals and they're all they're doing
all day long is working on they've got
testosterone pumping through them and
they've got all these kind of social
hierarchies and the ordinary order of
society goes completely insane and
surprise surprise you get some eccentric
sexual acts going on yeah that's true
that does happen important that's a
punch line or that does happen in prison
rather it's a punch line when people go
to prison you say oh I don't drop the
soap
but how does this relate to porn
saying if you turn on a gay porno you
might feel aroused
regardless of a stu if of whether or not
a student does feel aroused watching
from that kind of pornography
this is what grooming is
when when conservatives talk about
grooming this is what we're talking
about we're not just talking about some
drag queen weirdo leading a
five-year-old off into the woods by the
hands we're talking about this kind of
stuff what is grooming grooming is when
you cultivate sexual desire in somebody
else
it's not just that you go in and
violently take that person it's when you
are cultivating that desire the
professor is saying hey you're a
straight guy you don't think about doing
gay stuff well maybe you should maybe
you should actually engage in an
activity that is designed not merely to
satisfy sexual desires but to cultivate
them because that's what pornography
does that's what the Indulgence of all
lust does
this is why when you hear people talk
about pornography addiction and The
Perils of the industry and even the way
that the industry makes money the way it
makes money is on the basis that
pornography does not satiate lust it
inflames lust it encourages lust and it
leads people down really weird Alleyways
people who have have become to identify
as transgender and then they leave
transgenderism
lots and lots of them I would I would be
comfortable saying the vast majority of
them that I have heard or read of say
that porn was involved in some way
I said I started off watching kind of
normal-ish porn and then I started
watching weirder and weirder porn and
then eventually I started watching porn
that told me that I'm a woman
so it's cultivating that desire what
does this professor even think that
bisexual means
if you're a guy and you never think
about doing weird stuff with guys and
you never engage in weird stuff with
guys and you're perfectly attracted to
women and that's what's going on
throughout your whole life
and then this professor sits you down in
a chair and plays a bunch of gay porn
for you and then at the end of whatever
time period let's say at the end of six
months of this you start to have more
disordered sexual visions and desires
that means you're bisexual no it means
that guy made you bisexual it means that
guy encouraged that the desires in you
because he's making a normative
statement he's saying that is good it's
good to be gay it's good to be bisexual
it's good and it's bad not to be
it's like it's not just it's okay to be
gay it's not just not that there's
anything wrong with that which was the
kind of 1990s laissez-faire attitude to
these sexual questions
it's a claim that is that it is actively
good to pursue disordered sexual desires
and and why are people claiming this
it's not just because they're
sexual deviance like this professor
it follows naturally from the
liberationist theology that has told us
in increasingly absurd ways for the last
several centuries that we need to free
our true selves
not merely from the oppressive shackles
of tyrannical governments but from
convention
from morality from our families from our
physical bodies
from our religions certainly but even
from our bodies because my true self is
not my body
I've got it that's the argument
that people are making
and it's a false one I mean it's it's
whatever this professor has to say about
the psychological effects of porn he
probably knows a thing or two about it
because I'm sure he's watched a lot of
it
he doesn't know anything about ethics
morality he doesn't seem to know very
much about anthropology doesn't seem to
know very much about Theology and and he
is he is smuggling in all of those
theological philosophical
anthropological premises in this
Preposterous sort of class become a
member today use code Noel scanner
w-l-e-s at checkout for two months free
on a all-access plan any daily wire plan
you want dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout
[Music]
thank you